ich habe mir die Monopoly Reise in die
Zunge gekauft um das Spiel in Reallife
zu spielen wie gerade schon kurz erwähnt
schaut euch unbedingt zuerst die erste
Folge an sonst werdet ihr direkt
gespoilert dort ging es für mich auf
jeden Fall an die Küste von Lagos in
Portugal ein sehr sehr schöner Ort und
ich bin dann abends im Hotel in Faro
gelandet um zu ermitteln wo meine
weitere Reise hingeht bin gespannt ich
hoffe ihr auch viel Spaß mit der zweiten
Folge von Monopoly travel Edition in
real life und damit junge was geht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut wir
haben schon ziemlich spät ich bin tot
müde aktuell befinde ich mich in Faro
das hier ist der zweite Part von meiner
travel Monopoly Reise weil sie den
ersten Part noch nicht geschaut habt
schaut euch den unbedingt zuerst an ich
möchte mich jetzt auf jeden Fall schnell
hinlegen aber ich würde gerne vorher
planen weil ich sicherlich für morgen
noch irgendwie ein Flug organisieren
muss entweder von Faro oder von Lissabon
alle anderen Flughäfen sind viel zu weit
weg wo die weitere Reise hingeht
deswegen würde ich sagen will aber gar
nicht lange
wir haben hier schon mal die Karten
Spielfigur und Würfel hier hinten ja das
Spielfeld so okay ich bin echt gespannt
angefangen habe ich hier okay ihr wisst
ja jetzt eh wo ich bin hier küsste von
Lagos habe ich mir heute angeschaut ich
hatte einen unfassbar meisten
abenteuerlustigen aber auch sehr
anstrengenden Tag aber geil einmal diese
Reise Tagebuch Karten oder wie heißen
und das hier sind Events Ereignis fällt
genauso heißen die okay kann losgehen am
besten ich Würfel einfach mal hier
ja scheiße sorry
okay ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
hat dich nicht beim ersten Mal schon 11
ich glaube beim ersten Mal waren es auch
schon elf okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
ich dachte gerade erst Akropolis dass
wir eigentlich geil gewesen da war ich
noch nie aber es ist nahflug ach so und
als ich die Regeln aufgestellt habe habe
ich gesagt Leute einen Nachtrag noch es
gibt hier nach Flugfelder wenn ich
darauf Lande werde ich den günstigsten
Flug von der Stadt wo ich gerade bin
oder dem Ort wo ich gerade bin nehme und
es gibt Fernflüge falls ich auf diesem
Feld Lande werde ich den ersten
Langstreckenflug über 5000 km nehmen den
ich bekommen kann von dem Ort wo ich
halt gerade bin macht Sinn oder so Leute
was geht kurze Werbeunterbrechung ich
weiß manchmal auch echt random aber das
Reiseprojekt ist natürlich wieder sehr
teuer deswegen freue ich mich immer über
passende Sponsoren und ihr seht ja schon
ich bin an einem ganz anderen Ort um
euch ein bisschen Vorfreude zu
generieren da ist es mehr ich werde aber
doch gar nicht zu viel verraten schaut
euch einfach die nächsten Episode an das
heutige Video entsteht noch mal ein
Freundschaft Zusammenarbeit mit Papi
mobile kennt ihr vielleicht auch schon
aus einem meiner letzten Videos ein
super nices Handyspiel habe ich selber
schon ultra länger auf meinem Smartphone
drauf wurde zusammengefasst um was es
geht bis zu 100 Spieler treffen sich in
der Lobby steigenden Flugzeug fliegen zu
einer Map können dort an jegliche Spots
abspringen müssen und Items sammeln und
gegen andere Spieler so lange wie
möglich überleben Battle Royale mäßig
viele von euch kennen das Game
wahrscheinlich auch schon falls nicht
habt ihr auf jeden Fall was verpasst das
geile ist für mich so wie ich jetzt hier
durch meine Videos irgendwo in Spanien
Lande nimmt euch Papier vom 13 Juli bis
Anfang August mit in die Welt von Dragon
Ball und neben fünf neuen Charakteren
die hier mal eingewendet seht ihr könnt
natürlich mit jedem von den Charakteren
auch spielen gibt es neben den
bestehenden Maps auch drei neue Maps die
natürlich das Dragonball Universum der
präsentieren
ich sitze in letzter Zeit unfassbar oft
am Flughafen und muss generell irgendwo
warten da spielen immer ganz gerne
papchi mobile hier mein Gameplay von mir
so sieht das aus ihr könnt mich
natürlich auch gerne in Game adden holt
euch das neue Dragonball Update und
PlayStore in der Videobeschreibung
verlinkt viel Spaß beim draufdrücken und
wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem Video
aber geil Leute kurze Flashbacks an mein
Video ich buche jeden Tag die
günstigsten Flug falls du nicht gesehen
habt haben wir das glaube ich vier Tage
hintereinander gemacht ich habe
eingegeben Faro ist nämlich am nächsten
und dann klicken wir alle Orte und wir
wollen am Freitag den 14 fliegen Spanien
18 Euro
Valencia wow 18 Euro oh mein Gott nein
das ist ja voll früh Ryanair 7:25 Uhr
wir haben jetzt boah ich brauche
eigentlich mehr Schlaf als 6 Stunden
aber das werden wenn ich mich jetzt
hinlege maximal sechs Stunden werden
naja was willst du machen da müssen wir
den buchen und morgen geht's dann für 18
€ und jetzt sind 22 € ist trotzdem
scheißen günstig nach Valencia wo ich
auch noch nie in meinem Leben zuvor war
ich freue mich also Leute drückt mir die
Daumen dass ich gut erholsamen Schlaf
bekomme und morgen fit bin weil morgen
wird wahrscheinlich genauso hat wie
heute obwohl egal macht Spaß dass die
Hauptsache gute Nacht
und damit guten Morgen Leute ich bin
gerade aufgestanden wir haben viertel
vor sechs mein Flug geht in einer Stunde
25 Minuten schnell zum Flughafen und auf
geht's ich bin echt ich muss sagen ich
habe leider nur viereinhalb Stunden
Schlaf bekommen naja egal scheiß im
Flughafen noch was frühstücken und dann
geht's los nach Valencia ich freue mich
wenn keine Tag jetzt
habe ich alles an kurze Aufenthalt hier
tschüss
ist auch ein sehr hellhöriges Hotel hier
kann ich nicht so empfehlen aber gut hat
seinen halbwegs erfüllt
sorry das Checkouts
also die Hotelmitarbeiterin habe ich auf
jeden Fall gerade geweckt das hat ja ein
bisschen gedauert bis zu Rezeption kam
in Faro geht auf jeden Fall jetzt gleich
so langsam glaube ich die Sonne auf sehr
angenehme Luft hier dann setze ich mich
mal noch ein bisschen hier hin und warte
auf mein uber aber Alter ich werde hier
von Mücken aus Digger einfach das war
einfach eine Mücke
wTF was geht hier ab hier mein ganzer
Daumen ist voller Blut einfach weil ich
so gemacht habe und hier so eine fette
Mücke überfahrer du musst jetzt kommen
ich werde jetzt zerstochen
hallo hallo
[Musik]
so Leute da sind wir wieder lange nicht
gesehen den Flughafen hier weiter geht's
Faro war nice ich freue mich auf
Valencia ich wollte gerade eigentlich
noch in die Lounge gehen hier ein Fahrer
am Flughafen um zu frühstücken leider
macht ihr es um 7 Uhr auf also um 15
Minuten mein Geld schießt aber schon um
6:55 also wird das leider nichts jetzt
muss ich mir irgendwo anders einen
Kaffee kaufen naja aber unterm Strich
hat sich für mich trotzdem bis jetzt
sehr gelohnt das ganze ich habe mir auf
jeden Fall jetzt noch so einen Kaffee
aus dem Automaten gezogen aber ich
glaube es ist Kakao da ist so viel
Zucker drin ich kann es gar nicht sagen
irgendwie komisch die doch mehr aus wie
Kakao nee na ja los geht's
[Musik]
okay Leute 10 Uhr ich bin angekommen in
Valencia ich habe noch gar keinen Plan
was ich hier überhaupt machen soll aber
irgendwas wird sich schon ergeben okay
angekommen ich glaube ich nehme jetzt
erstmal die Metro das ging ja ganz gut
das wahrscheinlich auch günstigsten und
dann fahre ich mal ins City Center von
Valencia was muss man in Valencia machen
muss ich gleich mal googeln wie gesagt
ich war hier noch nie ich habe keine
Ahnung ich weiß nur es gibt ein
Fußballverein der heißt FC Valencia
sonst weiß ich gar nichts über die Stadt
aber Valencia liegt auch am Mittelmeer
genau das ist das Mittelmeer und nicht
mehr der Atlantik weil Faro ist ja an
der Atlantikküste deswegen war es
übrigens auch so windig das ist auf
jeden Fall die längste Metro Schlangen
die ich je gesehen habe für Ticket
[Musik]
gekauft ich habe nichts verstanden
in Deutschland werden jetzt 60 Euro
wegen Schwarzfahren fällig
danke
so 2,50 € gespart die kann ich jetzt in
Brötchen investieren weil ich habe noch
nichts gefrühstückt aber das war
natürlich nicht extra Leute also ich
habe einfach irgendwas gebucht ich
dachte mir wird schon passen und jetzt
schauen wir uns mal Valencia an WoW
[Musik]
erster Eindruck ist auf jeden Fall schön
und sehr heiß Leute ich mache mir jetzt
auf jeden Fall auf den Weg zum Kolonne
market das ist ein Markt da soll es wohl
ganz viele verschiedene Essenssachen
geben dann habe ich gefunden unter den
Top Sehenswürdigkeiten was man hier so
machen muss da sind natürlich auch so
ganz typische Turi Sachen bei
irgendwelche Sehenswürdigkeiten
Kathedrale oder irgendwelche alten
Gebäude das Problem bei mir ist nur ich
habe da gar keinen Bock drauf irgendwie
bin ich dann noch zu jung für dass ich
in Städte fahre und mir
Sehenswürdigkeiten reinziehe den ganzen
Tag Ich will irgendwie Leute
kennenlernen ein bisschen Action und
einfach gucken was passiert ich hoffe
damit könnt ihr Leben für die älteren
Zuschauer seid mir nicht böse aber da
müsst ihr euch einen anderen Youtuber
reinziehen und ich habe das Local wie
ein Portugal vergessen scheiße das muss
ich auf jeden Fall hier nachholen das
Ding ist durch kennen alle wir sollten
aus Spanien wobei vielleicht hat
Valencia auch ein Local Ding abstimmt so
und da sind wir auch schon das hier ist
soweit ich weiß der Kolon Marketing vor
aber
da gibt's sogar drei verschiedene Tagen
interessant ich muss auf jeden Fall
jetzt erstmal frühstücken sonst falle
ich dir gleich um aber hier werde ich
schon was finden erstmal frühstücken und
dann geht's
hallo das liest sich doch wunderbar
[Musik]
okay Leute gestärkt bin ich jetzt schon
mal jetzt geht es noch nach unten ein
Bier trinken mittags um 12 aber warum
auch nicht ne
altes one
momentia
also Leute hier habe ich meinen local
Bier
das kann ich später glaube ich noch gut
gebrauchen
sehr gut ich habe ja sonst auch immer
noch ein lokales Gericht überall
gegessen das Ding ist ich habe mich
jetzt dazu entschieden das sein zu
lassen weil eh immer Leute von euch
meckern das ist kein richtig lokales
Gericht ist und teilweise hat er noch
nicht geschmeckt und dann will ich
lieber einfach das essen worauf ich Bock
habe ist ja sicher egal oder aber das
wird mir weiter fort okay Leute das
war's mit dem colonmarkt ich muss sagen
kann man auf jeden Fall mal abchecken so
besonders ist es jetzt auch nicht also
interessant dass das in diesem Top 10
Sehenswürdigkeiten Blocks auftaucht aber
ich hatte schon meinen Spaß so es ist
unfassbar heiß hier wir haben heute 32
Grad und ich habe zwar viele kurze
Sachen dabei allerdings sind die alle so
ein bisschen dicker und bevor ich schaue
wie es weitergeht wo ich hier Penne ob
ich hier Penne was weiß ich lauf mir mal
kurz zu Zara und besorgen mir so einen
lässiges Tanktop die Männer sind -1 da
fühle mich jetzt aber diskriminiert kann
auch nicht sein nee Spaß ist mir
vollkommen egal direkt fündig geworden
eigentlich das sieht doch auch ziemlich
nice aus oder muss ich mal anprobieren
kurzer transition okay so sieht's aus
ich muss sagen ich bin nicht zu 100%
überzeugt aber es ist auf jeden Fall so
eine Mütze habe ich mir auch ausgesucht
zieht nur gerade hier mit dem ganzen
Equipment da oben drauf ein bisschen
komisch aus hauptsache es ist nicht so
warm deswegen nehme ich das jetzt mit
ach ja ich habe die Transition vergessen
wir sind auf jeden Fall echt viele
richtig nice Sachen Problem ist nur mein
Rucksack ist schon voll zu Ende
geschockt Leute und dann hatte ich
Hunger ich habe schon gesagt das
traditionelle Gericht das für mal
ausfallen ich hatte Bock auf indisch und
bin zum besten indischen Restaurant in
Valencia gegangen und habe da mein neues
Lieblingsgericht Butter chicken gegessen
für mich gibt's jetzt einfach in Spanien
indisch und zwar Butter chicken wir
haben das immer in Bangkok gegessen das
ist unfassbar geil und ich dachte mir
kommen ich habe da jetzt so Bock drauf
gut bewertet guten Appetit mega lecker
okay Leute ich habe aufgegessen ich muss
sagen langsam macht sich auch ein
bisschen die Müdigkeit breit bei mir vor
allem nach dem Essen ist das ja auch
üblich ja ich bin jetzt ein bisschen im
überlegen was ich mache weil ich fühle
mich gerade ein bisschen verloren muss
ich sagen gib mir mal ein bisschen
Bedenkzeit okay Leute ich befinde mich
mittlerweile immer noch irgendwo in
mitten von Valencia
wie man sehen kann gerade aktuell in
irgendeinem Park und meine Kamera ist 50
m weit weg ich hoffe sie wird es nicht
geklaut da links von euch sitzen so drei
Mädels die fragen sich wahrscheinlich
auch warum steht seine Kamera so weit
weg und der sitzt auf der Bank und dabei
in so ein kleines Ding auf jeden Fall
wollte ich nur sagen dass ich dieses
Video hier jetzt beenden werde und zwar
aus folgendem Grund ich werde jetzt
gleich nämlich noch mal Würfeln wir
haben jetzt ca 16 Uhr weil ich muss
sagen ich bin eigentlich jedes Jahr
einmal in Spanien und Spanien kenne ich
schon ziemlich gut ich will einfach mal
irgendwo hin wo ich noch nie war
irgendwie was anderes sehen und deswegen
falls es noch heute klappt werde ich
machen
die gucken mich alle so dumm an hier ich
gehe nicht davon aus also ich denke ich
werde in Valencia eine Nacht übernachten
müssen aber wir schauen mal ich hoffe
das sieht deutlich gefallen abonniert
sehr sehr gerne den Kanal und wir sehen
uns schon bald wieder ich bin gespannt
wo es dann hingeht und jetzt schnell weg
hier